talking about
scary things like um i mean
i hate to be asking a cliche boring
question but i think if it's me
asking you it's kind of a dope question
like
it's a scary jackass moment like uh
some of the gnarly i don't know because
i've been asked that question a whole
bunch of times
and i don't know what the scariest thing
is right we because we've been around
with wild boys and stuff too we've been
at around anaconda snakes on us
you and i have laid tigers we've i've
jumped off
bridges with tied to preston you know so
there there's this thing where it's i
think i'm more of an adrenaline
junkie than a feared junkie all right
because you're just desensitized to it
here's the thing and i should say that
i'm embarrassed for asking that question
in the first place
because i get the same [__] so much all
the time too
and i always kind of stick with the same
answer that when it comes to scary
situations
like you know you max out at a certain
you know it's not one's not scary or
another because once you're scared to a
certain point
you can't you can't get more scared and
like
there's so many different examples of
times where we maxed out
that you know it's apples and oranges
and and
yeah yeah i think for me like something
that i would never do
out of like anything that you guys have
done would be when manny grabbed the
tail of the [__] lion dude
right that's heavy metal right even
though
even though it was a captive lion you
know i don't mind
it's like going to tiger land i don't
know i can't i don't think
it's kind of hard to fight the the
the hot the danger of okay it's a
captive lion
sure right because you can you'll see
siegfried and roy
yeah go into cages and go well you know
we're cool because they're captive and
dude
you know like right i'm the tiger king
yeah or the tiger king and it's joe
exotic [__] yeah
the joe exotic [__] [__] [__] lost
an arm
the best part of it was when joe then
throws on a paramedic jack and goes all
right i got this
yeah where did that come from dude like
what was that jacket
get the paramedic jacket right now right
and siegfried and roy
they they did the las vegas thing with
the tigers
and i don't know if it's siegfried or
roy but one of them is a straight-up
[__] vegetable because the tiger just
[__]
chomped his head like a [__] cheeto
and dude when when we were filming with
the same captive lions
in california doing this nintendo
commercial
and uh where i'm up in the tree i
like i'm gonna make a video of time yeah
we could have died for sure
and times we just straight up could have
died and that's like for sure one of
them
but i was making fun of siegfried and
roy in the tree and then
just comes up he was licking you he was
licking you
like he was like oh this is a good piece
of meat and after this third
oh my god that's what i'm gonna fight
were you there no but i've seen the
photo dude i wasn't there but i've seen
them and he kept reading
like i was like bro like what was going
through your mind
um i i mean i i stopped delivering my
lines and i started saying good kitty
good kitty it's a [__] 300 pound
african lion yeah captivity doesn't do a
whole lot no
no what other times have you what other
times have you guys almost died
if you could think about ah we didn't
die
but one of the fun ones was when we were
on the back of the elephant me chris and
stevo
and the elephant just took off remember
we're all just holding each other like
don't let go don't let go
stay on just stay off in kenya i mean it
wasn't that bad but
it's a fun one that's dude there should
be two versions
of uh of the video times i almost died
while working like for work and then
times we almost
died like you know like honor
in our personal time get ready this is
to be gnarly
pretty gnarly kind of normal are we
ready yeah
[Music]
what's up denver
women can paint their boobs and show
them on instagram
so i figure i should be able to paint my
dick and do whatever i want
make some noise for my brother
[Applause]
wait let me inspect for crabs this time
when my buddies lit that stuff right
away i knew
i [__] up
i'm not doing this to hurt your dad
you're gonna hurt me you're gonna piss
me off